it is now four days since the supreme
court overruled roe v wade there has
been a flurry of commentary you may
recall that my show had already aired by
the time the decision came down on
friday i was on an airplane i rushed to
the studio right after i landed and gave
my breakdown of the ruling i certainly
was not the only one
there has been
a flurry of commentary around the
decision
but in a matter of just a few days i
have found it i have found
the single worst reaction to the supreme
court's decision in dobbs to overrule
roe v wade brought to you by cnn's anna
navarro
and because i have a family with a lot
of special needs kids i have a brother
who's 57 and has the mental and motor
skills of a one-year-old and i know what
that means financially emotionally
physically for a family and i know not
all families can do it and i have a step
granddaughter who was born with a down
syndrome and you know what it is very
difficult in florida to get services it
is not as easy as it sounds on paper and
i've got another another step grandson
who is uh very autistic who has autism
and it is incredible and their mothers
and people who are in that society who
are in that community will tell you that
they've considered suicide because
that's how difficult it is to get help
because that's how lonely they feel
because they can't get other jobs
because they have financial issues
because the care that they're able to
give their other children
suffers
the supreme court's ruling is bad you
see according to anna navarro because
now it won't be as easy to kill people
with mental disabilities and she's not
even speaking in the abstract she's
speaking of her own family she's saying
you know i have this brother who's got
mental disabilities i have a
step-grandchildren with mental
disabilities and
and they're alive and that's horrible
it's so annoying that they're if they
were dead our lives would be so much
better that's what she's saying
congratulations anna you managed to beat
out joe biden and aoc and a whole host
of other contenders whose opinions were
also ignorant and evil but not quite so
obviously so i'm michael knowles the
michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment on friday is from ryu who says i
hate to take a page out of the left's
playbook but
this is a wonderful first step we have a
long way to go
i'd love to take a page out of the
left's playbook not on the substance of
what they want obviously but in terms of
procedure those guys are pretty clever
you know they've figured out political
tactics pretty well and they were
extremely successful for
i don't know the last 60 years or so so
yeah let's take that page out baby the
roe v wade decision
or rather the dobbs decision to have a
rule review aid wonderful excellent
really the most wonderful political
event of my lifetime
most of all a good first step
that anna navera reaction is so
hideous it's
it's one of the worst
things i've ever heard in political
commentary
not just that we should we should kill
certain people but we should kill
extremely vulnerable people not just
that we should kill extremely vulnerable
people we should kill extremely
vulnerable members of our own family
because sometimes they might seem a
little inconvenient to us
her opinion is not an outlier it's not
unique
the left has been talking about this for
years they just usually have the sense
to speak a little more euphemistically
than anna navero is fortunately because
she's not as intelligent as the rest of
the left she says the quiet part out
loud but iceland was bragging about this
a few years ago there was a big headline
out of iceland breaking iceland
eradicates down syndrome
there's no cure to down syndrome they
didn't eradicate it in the sense of
curing people who have it they just now
kill every single person just about who
has down syndrome in iceland so they can
say it's erratic it's eradicated because
you're committing genocide that right
that's that's the eradication not
something exactly that you should be
proud of
and you see it of course you see it when
you go into a doctor's office
when
a woman becomes pregnant you go see the
obstetrician
you will
be asked if you want to have certain
genetic tests and you say
why would we have these tests done
they say well look the tests are done so
that you can find out any abnormalities
if anything might be wrong you're going
to test for down syndrome and then we
can figure out how to proceed
what do you what are we going to figure
out oh you know then we'll just kind of
make a decision on how you what decision
you want him oh you're asking me if i
want to kill my kid because he's
[ __ ] that's what you're saying
you're saying we're going to do a test
and we're going to find out if the kid
is [ __ ] and then we're gonna suggest
that you kill him
and you know the craziest part
is it's it's more politically incorrect
it is more socially unacceptable to say
the word [ __ ] than it is to kill a
[ __ ] person killing a [ __ ]
person totally fine
totally encouraged promoted they're
whining on cnn because you're not
allowed to do it
but you can't say the word
don't you no you have to watch your
language while you're killing people
does that make a lot of sense i don't
think so joe biden is saying practically
the same thing not with regard to people
who have mental disabilities but with
regard to the poor he tweeted out quote
the cruel truth is that overturning roe
will hit poor women and girls the
hardest
that's the cruel truth what is cruel
about that
oh you're saying it is cruel
that now
we won't be able to kill the poor
right poor women women who don't have a
lot of money
now will find it a little bit more
difficult in certain states to kill
their children and this is really cruel
and terrible because now we're going to
have more poor people and we're going to
have to deal with them and isn't that
isn't that annoying
can't i mean this is jonathan swift
level stuff this is eat the irish babies
because we don't want them around kind
of stuff
it's not coming even from some lunatic
on cnn that's coming from the president
of the united states
the takes on on the roe over ruling have
been from the left have been
almost uniformly evil but when they're
not evil they are extremely stupid and
this is where we have to turn to aoc aoc
says that the supreme court
sending the issue of abortion back to
the states and the people and the
people's representatives
represents
a crisis of
democracy
what i believe that the president and
the democratic party needs to come to
terms with is that this is not just a
crisis of roe this is a crisis of our
democracy the supreme court has
dramatically
overreached its authority
we had
two
conservative senators in the united
states senate senator manchin and
senator collins come out with a very
explosive allegation that these that
several supreme court justices misled
them in their during their confirmation
hearings and in the lead-up to their
confirmation this is a crisis of
legitimacy we have a supreme court
justice whose wife participated in
january 6 and who used his seat to vote
against providing documents that
potentially led to evidence of such to
congrat to investigators in congress
this is a crisis of legitimacy and
president biden must address that
absolute crisis of legitimacy crisis of
democracy what's the crisis
what's the crisis
aoc at the end there you hear she's
going after clarence thomas and his wife
ginny which the libs have been doing for
decades because ginny is a conservative
political activist and so they find and
they've been going after clarence thomas
since before he was confirmed
the larger claim that they're making
here is that the conservative justices
misled people and this therefore creates
a great crisis for our democracy
the dobbs decision
is very possibly the most pro-democracy
decision that we have ever had in the
history of the court
the dobbs decision represents one branch
of government the judiciary
giving away an issue
sending an issue back to where it had
existed for all of american history
until 1973 namely to the legislatures to
the democracy
it's a crisis of democracy how is it a
crisis of democracy when the people get
more of a say on an on a political issue
that of course is not a crisis of
democracy that that's an expansion of
democracy but it just reminds you that
when the libs talk about democracy they
don't really mean democracy this is how
it can be the case that when
more people vote for donald trump than
vote for hillary clinton
in the states where it matters where the
electoral college plays a role also in
this election
where the where the democratic process
favors donald trump over hillary clinton
that's a crisis of democracy
how
he won the people yeah but
but we didn't get the outcome we wanted
when more people in hungary vote for the
right-wing candidate victor orban then
vote for the left-wing candidate that's
a crisis of democracy democracies in
peril
how's that that's not that's just
manifestly absurd well it's the case
because when they say democracy they
don't mean democracy they mean
liberalism they mean leftism they mean
progressivism they mean whatever policy
agenda they want they can't lose
legitimately so whenever they do lose it
has to be a crisis of
legitimacy because for the progressive
left progress is clear they're on the
right side of history the arc of history
bends toward aoc or whatever and so when
whenever anything interrupts that that
march toward utopia that march
inevitably toward progress then it has
to be
it has to be a stolen election it has to
be the russians interfering it has to be
uh hanging chads in florida it has to be
it has to be anything other than what it
obviously is
in this case and and beyond which is
that the people don't exactly like what
the libs are doing
we got to protect our country we got to
protect our homes that's why you got to
check out ring right now go to ring.com
knowles it's summer and people are
traveling you know i've been on the road
for the past week i was in la santa
barbara i was in chicago i was all over
the place okay and when i'm on the road
i can feel safe because of a ring you
know you know ring you're gonna say ring
the video doorbell company yes they have
an amazing video doorbell where you can
see and speak to whoever's at your door
wherever you are in the house outside
the house wherever you know they've got
an alarm so they've got ring alarm that
protects your doors and your windows and
your whole physical home from freeze
fire flood and the bad guys
now you got to go pro be like me okay
become a pro cnet calls ring alarm pro a
giant leap for home security
it is this amazing award-winning alarm
that protects not just your physical
home but your digital home too it
protects everything whether you're in
the home whether you're away from the
home you're just gonna feel safe the
cost is unbelievably low compared to the
other guys
you may not have known it but it is true
ring has that award-winning alarm this
busy summer season to protect all of our
homes you got to go pro with ring alarm
pro go to ring.com knowles ring.com
knowles
aoc claims that the justices misled the
senate she she goes even further she
says the justices lied
if we allow
supreme court nominees to lie under
earth under oath and secure lifetime
appointments to the highest court of the
land and then issue
issue without basis if you read these
opinions issue without basis rulings
that deeply undermine the human and
civil rights of
of the of the majority of americans
we must see that through there must be
consequences for
such a deeply destabilizing action and
hostile takeover of our democratic
institutions to allow that to stand is
to allow it to happen and what makes it
particularly dangerous is that it sends
a blaring
signal to all future nominees that they
can now lie
to duly elected members of the united
states senate in order to secure supreme
court uh nomin confirmations and and and
seats on the supreme court there is so
much that is funny in that babble that
she just spewed out there she to allow
that to stand is to allow that
to happen and if and you can tell she's
just rich if if if you read the decision
and in the and to say the things and the
decision that frankly without basis no
she doesn't cite any examples of course
because
i highly doubt she has even read the
decision because it's over 200 pages and
there aren't pictures you know it's not
a coloring book so she hasn't hasn't
probably made it through we went through
the decision on friday when i did my
bonus show because it's an
extraordinarily interesting opinion
you've got the opinion of the court
which is they're going to uphold the
pro-life law and they're going to
overrule roe versus wade and casey and
they say that this the constitution
doesn't say anything about an abortion
and so it goes back to the states you've
got the
roberts concurring opinion which says
we're gonna uphold the pro-life law but
we're not i wish we weren't gonna
overrule rowan casey you've got
kavanaugh who says we're gonna pull the
pro-life law we're gonna overrule rowan
casey we are not gonna make any
decisions about abortion so kavanaugh is
agreeing entirely with the opinion of
the court but he's going even further to
aoc's point she says that this
represents a takeover of our democratic
institutions kavanaugh says exactly the
opposite he says no no we are expanding
democracy here we are not taking
anything we are giving away a power that
the court illegitimately usurped in 1973
to make a decision on abortion we have
no decision on abortion we are we are
only sending this back to the people and
the people's representatives then you
had justice thomas's concurrence
which was the best part of the entire
opinion as far as i'm concerned at least
in terms of its legal logic which
pointed out that actually
although the court is is trying to make
a big point of how
the the reasoning in this case is not
going to threaten
cases like griswold cases like lawrence
v texas cases like obergefell cases on
condoms on gay sex on gay marriage and
all of these rights that were discovered
somewhere in the constitution who knew
there was a right to condoms in the
constitution probably not probably not
james madison probably not the founding
fathers and the framers
thomas goes even further he says
actually we should revisit these
questions
even if we want to have condoms and gay
sex and redefine marriage you might want
to do all of those things that's
that's neither here nor there
we just want to point out it's not in
the constitution it's not there no one
seriously believes that this radical
definition of marriage that it hasn't
existed
beyond five minutes ago that that was
present in the constitution in the 1780s
and 90s we just we just know it's not
there
show me the invisible ink i haven't been
able to see it yet so she makes that
there's a little bit of a digression she
makes all these points if you read the
liberal descent
there's really no argument there the
liberal descent
the the nearest thing to a legal
argument is that
it is that because of starry decisis
because of the principle that
that rulings and precedence should just
persist even if they weren't argued all
that all that convincingly that was
pretty much it and the the second part
of the dissent is that if you get rid of
of roe v wade you're going to get rid of
all these other things that liberals
like but they didn't really make
arguments from the constitution they
didn't really make any argument that roe
was rightly decided because no one
thinks roe was rightly decided frankly
ruth bader ginsburg thought that the the
logic of the roe versus white decision
was ridiculous
she liked the outcome of the decision
but she didn't she didn't agree with the
legal argument so aoc babbling babbling
babbling and then there's the cherry on
top which is she says that the justices
lied you're going to hear this so much
from the left over the next few days
barrett and kavanaugh and gorsuch and
alito they lied before congress before
the senate
when they were being confirmed why
because they said
that roe was precedent that roe was
settled law here's the here is exactly
what the justices said alito
roe v wade is an important president of
the supreme court gorsuch that's the law
of the land i accept the law of the land
kavanaugh it's settled as a president of
the supreme court barrett roe v wade
clearly held that the constitution
protected a woman's right to terminate a
pregnancy
aoc says those are lies because they
voted to overrule it
not a single word there is a lie
alito gorsuch kavanaugh they didn't say
anything that that wasn't true
roe v wade was an important president
met by the supreme court
roe v wade was the law of the land
roe v wade did clearly hold that a woman
has a right to an abortion
that was all true
then
that is not true now
and it's not true because now we've got
a new precedent and i cannot wait for
the next well i can't wait i want to
wait a long time for the next liberal
supreme court justice
but once the next liberal supreme court
justice is selected and goes through the
confirmation process
i cannot wait for the republicans to
grill that justice
say all right justice so and so
justice ocasio-cortez all right all
right
potential future judge ocasio-cortez
do you accept that dobbs versus jackson
women's health organization is the law
of the land
and just wait to hear what they say
because probably what what the liberal
judge is going to have to do is the
exact sort of verbal tricks that the
conservative justices did it's not even
really a trick they're saying yes this
is precedent
everyone knows what that means
but now but now we've got a new
precedent now we've got a new law of the
land and it happens to be the correct
one
so once aoc makes these claims it's not
just her it's biden's all these people
are really really furious over the dobbs
decision
the democrats in congress decided to
take a break from investigating an
insurrection you know january january 6
the worst interaction ever in history
they decided to take a break from that
to incite an insurrection aoc comes out
she says this is illegitimate and we
need to get into the streets
[Music]
both of those phrases
are calls to insurrection
she's saying illegitimate she's saying
the government is illegitimate
if that is not a pretext for an
insurrection i don't know what is and
then she says into the streets
if you had scripted this
and said hey what is the pithiest way to
call for an insurrection since we're all
talking about insurrections and that's
what you would say said the government
is illegitimate take to the streets
now i know aoc was supposed to be
investigating this insurrection but she
took a little break not just her maxine
waters who's always known for her
extremely dangerous red rhetoric she
comes out and she says we need to defy
the court
you see this turn out here
you ain't seen nothing yet
women are going to control their bodies
no matter how they try and stop us they
held with the supreme court we will defy
them women will be in control of their
bodies and if they think black women are
intimidated or afraid they got another
thought coming black women will be out
in droves we will be out by the
thousands we will be out by the millions
we are going to make sure we fight by
the right to control everybody thank you
the hell with the supreme court we will
defy them that's what maxine waters is
saying
on january 6 the worst day in history
there were
activists who said
they didn't even say the hell with
congress we will defy them they said we
are going to
uh challenge the the electoral count
because of the weird way in which this
election was conducted and then you know
and then obviously some people got
excited and they went into the capital
and some of them broke in and some of
them were let in by the police and some
were just followed in and it was
it was a strange situation
maxine waters is going further than
those people did maxine waters is saying
we will defy
a co-equal branch of government
to hell with the equal branch of
government it's not legitimate we're
going to go we're going to defy them
we're going to take
to the streets sounds sort of like an
insurrection
to me
june has been one of the biggest months
in the history of our country one of the
best months in the history of our
country best pride month ever by the way
it's also been one of the biggest months
in daily wire history and we still have
a week to go we had what is a woman
matt's documentary it's got a 97 score
on rotten tomatoes over 5 000 ratings we
had the book the follow-up book what is
a woman national bestseller we had the
premiere of our blockbuster movie of the
summer terror on the prairie starring
gina carano
and now this week on wednesday june 29th
at 8 pm eastern we will be back stage we
will be backstage live at the ryman you
will see your favorite daily wire host
and the other ones too you'll see me
i'll be there and then all the other
guys i like you've never seen us before
taking on the cultural and political
topics of the day
describing what backstage live is like
does not do it justice take a look
welcome to the daily wire backstage live
at the famous ryman
auditorium it was amazing we were in the
presence of greatness the energy of
having everyone on the same page was
amazing if your family member is still
waiting for fauci to give them
permission to leave their house it might
be time to cut that off
i'm actually pretty excited to meet all
of them i love everybody's opinion
individually i don't have a favorite i
like them all i had found out a way to
make football players cry in high school
my high school experience
i'm just excited to be here and be
surrounded by like-minded people and to
just you know feel that energy who
should we remove from office yeah one
politician the most powerful politician
in the country conductor
we're doing culture here i'm so thrilled
to see this happening if they say to
half of the country you can't that half
of the country needs to say screw you we
will
backstage live happens right here in
nashville on june 29th get your tickets
now
tune in to backstage live at the ryman
this wednesday june 29th 8pm eastern
become a daily wire member by going to
dailywire.com slash knowles use code
knowles for 25 off your membership that
is dailywire.com
knowles we'll be right back with a lot
more
the takes on the dobbs decision have
been mostly terrible
certainly from the left they've been
terrible from the right they've been
generally good though
a little bit of a mixed bag though a
little bit of a mixed bag depending on
how you define right and left it's not
just the far left
liberals who are
who are
rending their garments and gnashing
their teeth
bar stool sports the stool presidente
dave portenoid
after the decision came down he took to
social media to lambast the judges for
overruling roe v wade
okay emergency press conference uh roe
vs wade just got overturned let me start
by saying this is a dave portney press
conference this doesn't reflect barcelo
all right barcelo is 300 whatever people
they all may think certain ways is just
me how i feel i feel like i have to
speak on this issue i already talked
about a little bit to me this is just
pure insanity pure incentive we are
going backwards in time
we are literally going backwards in time
it makes no sense how anybody thinks
it's their right to tell a woman what to
do with her body i just don't get it to
take away the ability to make informed
decisions on how they want to live their
lives is bananas i honestly believe 95
of people in the country think like me
they're like they're liberally
they're socially liberal and they're
financially conservative they like 90 of
what republicans they don't like the
world culture all this craziness but
then you look at what they're doing and
it's like you're taking away basic
rights what's next same-sex marriage
like what is next it's insane
so obviously dave portnoy has absolutely
no idea what he's talking about here i
don't mean to dunk on the guy or totally
own him with facts and logic or anything
like that but he is just completely
wrong on the facts he's even wrong on
his political factor he said i believe
that 95 of the country thinks like me
they're fiscally conservative and
socially liberal that's just not true
nate silver at 538 the the pollster took
a poll of the country
tried to figure out how large the
fiscally
conservative socially liberal demo is
it's about 15 percent
it's not 95 it's 15 it's one of the
smallest electoral groups in the country
and a lot of people who are in fancy
institutions and live in big cities and
hang around and hobnob with rich fancy
people they they would call themselves
fiscally conservative socially liberal
because they want to do whatever they
want in their personal lives but they
don't want to pay a lot of taxes they're
just sort of like greedy democrats and
i'm not even saying that to be really
mean to them or anything
but the perception of how large that
demo is is so skewed when you run in
these circles it's a very very small
group it's an important group because
they can swing elections 15 is not
nothing but it's it's not the dominant
group in the country far from it so
dave portnoy says look i'm fiscally
conservative socially liberal
and i can't believe that the supreme
court would would make this kind of
ruling he later tweeted out he said come
on this is crazy the constitution's so
old don't you think it's kind of
outdated do you think the founding
fathers and the framers would would
really want us to still be operating
under this old dusty constitution that's
crazy
now
dave's wrong about that because
he doesn't appear to understand the
meaning of the word constitution
the constitution is not just some law
it's not just some statute or something
it is
the constitution it's the fundamental
framework of the country
yes the framers believed that the
constitution would last you you had one
line
from thomas jefferson in one of his
extreme radical flights of fancy where
he said we need a revolution every 15
years or something to that effect but
beyond that one little pithy quote that
people sometimes bring up
no of course the framers of the
constitution
the founding fathers believed that this
would endure and you could amend it and
you could pass laws and the country
obviously can change but the
constitution has to endure that's why
it's the constitution
and from the perspective of the
constitution there is no question
the dobbs ruling
was the constitutional
ruling
even the honest liberals will admit it
even though they really like abortion so
then you send it back to the people and
you send it back to the states and they
can make their own
decisions
the the portnoy video is important
because it reminds us that
bar stool conservatism is not
conservatism
it's it's important
i also don't want to just write it off
and say these guys you know should go
should go vote for the left they
probably will go vote for the left that
portnoy in that video says i'm gonna
have to vote for democrats now and okay
that's too bad i hope he doesn't vote
for democrats but if if we're gonna lose
him on an issue like this then we're
going to lose them
no i'm not willing to kill a million
babies a year to win dave portnoy's vote
and i'm not willing to kill a million
babies a year to win
15 of the electorate and no i'm not
willing to
beyond the issue of life i'm not willing
to completely subvert the constitution
and the judiciary and our system of
government to mollify a group of
sort of young decadent people who want
to go out and have fun but not fund the
welfare state
it's not that's not going to happen it's
not a good it's not the right thing to
do and it's politically a losing
it's a losing move
we need a a big coalition
the traditionalists the real
conservatives the socially conservative
that's not large enough
to win every single election in every
single place so we need coalitions but
the lines have to be clear here folks
you know what at a certain point if if
you have a tent that's too big it's
you're going to blur all of your lines
you're not going to have a political
movement at all so we need
highly precise
tactical coalitions of political
convenience but let's not let's not
pretend that we all think the same thing
here we don't and and and let's also by
the way
not give away all of our leverage to
mollify an extremely small group of
voters we we cannot allow ours this is
something the conservative movement did
for decades it was a huge mistake and we
lost as a result of it we cannot allow
the minority party of the political
coalition to call all of the shots
which is what happened with the fiscal
conservative social liberal people for
decades
because
when you've got a coalition of socially
conservative fiscally conservative
people and fiscally conservative
socially liberal people whatever you
know the the
kind of guys who want to just go out and
party and not pay a lot of taxes
when you come together in a political
coalition very often all that means is
you just do whatever the social liberals
want to do public liberalism private
conservatism which is to say you concede
your conservative beliefs can't do that
we look we have a common enemy the
wokeness the craziness
the radical left yes that's true let's
work together let's fight that common
foe
but
let's not pretend we're all the same
thing here we gotta we gotta fight that
foe take down that foe
but but no we're not we're not going to
give up life we're not going to give up
the constitution we're not going to give
up the judiciary because a very small
group of people wants to have
promiscuous sex all the time it's it's
not going to happen it's not worth it
okay speaking of polls
usa today has a really great poll out
here and it's a poll actually that
backs up what the social conservatives
and the constitutionalists are saying
and it undercuts the argument that dave
and some of the more socially liberal
types are making
dave's argument is gosh you know there
are all these voters who want to vote
for republicans but then you go out and
you defend life and you defend the
constitution and all of a sudden people
get really really angry about it and
they're going to vote for dems that's
not what the polls show
according to the polls
abortion is not the top issue for almost
anybody usa today suffolk university
poll came out on friday on dobbs day
showed that just under 15 there's that
number again
just under 15
of likely voters viewed abortion as the
most important election issue heading
into the midterms
now the majority of respondents say that
abortion is an important issue
sure we think about abortion
but it's not the top issue it's only 15
do you know what the top issue is for
people
the economy
only 23 percent of voters
say that abortion is more important than
the economy
that's 23
that includes the pro-lifers so it's
between the pro-lifers and the radical
abortion activists still only 23 percent
of the electorate thinks that abortion
is more important than the economy 66
percent said that the economy is the
most important
issue for their vote
the economy is in the doldrums and it's
all joe biden's fault and everyone knows
that it's joe biden's fault and he's
trying to blame it on putin and he's
trying to blame it on global warming and
he's trying to blame it on whatever and
it's not that's not persuasive
some there are some squishes who are
saying uh why did this ruling have to
come out sure it's going to save
hundreds of thousands of babies a year
sure it restores integrity or to our
judicial system but now we might lose
the midterms
there is no evidence that this will hurt
us in the midterms even if it won there
actually there was a poll that came out
some months ago that showed that the
abortion issue
did increase motivation among democrats
but it increased motivation among
republicans even more
so as a net
the republicans win on the pro-life
issue
but then it doesn't even matter so much
because abortion isn't the top
issue
this is uniformly
a win
this is uniformly a win it's the
greatest political event of my lifetime
why did it happen i've been i have been
scratching my head a little bit why now
that roe v wade comes down in 1973 then
in 1992 the court has the chance to
overrule it everyone knew that the the
decision was nonsense
actually
the case that ended up upholding the
quote-unquote right to an abortion
even admitted that the row decision was
was silly that the the opinion in row
was was poorly argued
that was planned parenthood v casey but
in 92 you had these squish conservative
quote-unquote judges who voted to uphold
the quote-unquote right to an abortion
which never existed in the constitution
and now the the court acknowledges that
it does not exist there
so why now what changed i think part of
it is
that the democrats changed their
rhetoric
they went from safe legal and rare to
shout your abortion abortion on demand
without apology
people might be able to get behind safe
legal and rare i suspect dave portnoy
and the rest of people who are just kind
of you know they don't pay a ton of
attention to politics
they
they're they're a swing vote they're
kind of swayed more easily between one
side or the other i bet they could get
behind safe legal and rare moderate
republicans can get behind safe legal
and rare very often
shout your abortion on demand for that
apology
even some center leftists don't like
that
anna navarro going on tv saying listen
we need legal abortion because i have a
[ __ ] brother and we should have
killed him and i've got these two
step-step grandchildren and man they
should be dead i'm really sad that
they're alive it's annoying they're
they're expensive and annoying because
they're [ __ ] that's what she's
saying
or they have some other mental
disability or they have or they're just
or i don't know they just bugged me when
they came over to the house on saturday
we should kill them i think ordinary
people are looking at that and they're
saying
oh my
what you monster you psycho what no
whatever man whatever you're whatever
side you're on i'm on the other side of
that
so i think that turned people off but
but why did the libs even change their
rhetoric if safe legal and rare was
working why did they change it to shout
your abortion on demand with that
apology
they did it because i think of the logic
of of abortion
if if abortion is murder
then it shouldn't be legal
if abortion is not murder if it's just
like getting your appendix taken out
then there's no reason it should be rare
safe legal and rare never made any sense
and it collapsed under the weight of its
own incoherence
same with the issue
in in the womb same with the physical
manifestation of the issue as sonograms
advance
you can just see it's a baby it's a baby
it's human it's living it's a baby
and i think people see that that that
has really helped the pro-life issue you
might say it's an idea whose time has
come
finally took a long time but it's it's
come and
for those of you who look out at the
world and see symbolism
i i meant to get to this on friday and i
didn't get to
there were some weird coincidences on
friday on the day the dobbs decision
came out
for those of you who are catholic in the
audience you will know that that
friday was the solemnity of the sacred
heart of jesus this is a very very high
the highest level feast you can have in
the year and it was the the solemnity of
jesus's sacred heart
it also coincidentally
was the feast of the nativity of saint
john the baptist and you will recall
that at the visitation
the one of the biblical arguments
against abortion and for the sanctity of
life is that when mary goes to visit
elizabeth mary is pregnant with jesus
and elizabeth is pregnant with john the
baptist when mary approaches with jesus
inside of her john the baptist leaps in
in elizabeth's womb
sensing the arrival of his lord and
savior jesus so
that symbolism was quite a lot for me
and then i i was reading cnn why i don't
know and i see this headline this is
this is from june 23rd the night before
the road decision
7 48 p.m eastern standard time
five planets take center stage as they
align in the night sky
bear with me here
first line a rare five planet alignment
will peak on june 24th
on dobbs day allowing a spectacular
viewing of mercury venus morris jupiter
and saturn as they line up in planetary
order
so
i'm just point i don't want to sound
hippy-dippy here folks but there is such
a thing as providence it's an evil
generation that seeks for signs and
wonders but to quote my friend and
priest father george rutler it's a
stupid generation that ignores signs and
wonders and as far as i can tell the
signs of the times
uh the
protection of life the beginning of the
protection of life the
the
overruling of the worst supreme court
decision in our history
is an idea whose time
has come
now
the the road decision was always
illogical speaking of illogic i have to
turn to our vice president who
was recently babbling incoherently about
the strength of our nation
the strength of our nation
has always been
that despite the odds and the obstacles
we push
to move forward
that we are guided by what we see
that can be
unburdened
by what has been
and we can see man
we can see that i am
me and you are you and we too
can come together and do
and do
for our nation
what would cause uh celebration
okay yeah are you with me kamala harris
is the you want to talk about ideas
whose times have come you want to talk
about the the logic of certain ideas
kamala harris is the consequence of 40
years of liberal bourgeois women reading
self-help books
because what what she was trying to do
was sound inspiring
and she she did that by just reciting
empty platitudes i think she was trying
to do an obama impression but obama was
a somewhat skilled rhetorician and so he
would say meaningless statements as well
but they sounded a little better when he
he was a little more adept at it she is
not very adept at it and so it just
sounds like nothing it's just totally
hollow
and
and it ties back into dobbs it ties back
into dubs if you read
the the court's opinion in dobbs the
logic is crystal clear anyone could read
it it's a very learned
opinion with many many pages of
citations and it it's a very high level
legal document but i bet you a 10 year
old could read that document because the
logic is so crystal clear
the argument is so crystal clear
and then you read the descent
and then you listen to aoc and then you
listen to biden and then you listen to
maxine waters and then you listen to all
of these people and you can't really
follow it and it's all contradictory a
woman has certain rights and we actually
don't even know what women are and and
abortion is
just a matter it's a personal decision
for a woman and unless she wants the
baby in which case then the baby is a
baby but the baby's not a baby and it's
it's in the constitution somewhere uh
but we haven't seen exactly where
and so that the logic was just
totally
uh
non-existent it just wasn't there and so
at a certain point
i i
i do think people wake up to that kind
of thing and a certain no matter how
thick the rhetoric how
how intense the emotional manipulation
can be i think that's what comes out
we've just gotten an update another
update from the supreme court this is
the greatest
man this is the greatest pride month
ever i
actually want pride month to continue i
thought i wanted pride month to end but
i i now i wanted to continue to keep
getting these rulings so we've just
gotten rulings uh within the last few
weeks defending the second amendment
defending the right to keep and bear
arms in new york we've gotten rulings in
favor of religious liberty the religious
liberty of of parents to send their kids
to christian schools not to have those
schools discriminated against we
obviously had the dobbs decision which
is the most important decision in the
history of the supreme court now now
we've just gotten word i haven't read
anything about it i just got a few words
typed in to my screen up there that the
supreme court has ruled in favor of
coach kennedy
that this was a supreme court case about
the right of a high school football
coach to have a private prayer after the
game
so this is a football coach who
after his football games whether he won
or lost he would get down on his knees
on the field and just have a little
prayer by himself he wasn't making other
people pray with him and
he he was fired for this
he was he was threatened he was
intimidated he was bullied and so he
brings this case
to court goes all the way up to the
supreme court it was an irony from the
very beginning of it which is that
for the last seven years or so the left
in this country has celebrated kneeling
at football games but they only want you
to kneel if you're kneeling to protest
the american flag but if you have the
temerity to kneel to give thanks to god
that's not allowed so they they brought
this case and the supreme court i don't
have the numbers i don't have the vote i
don't have the opinion
but we do know that the supreme court
has ruled in favor of coach kennedy this
is the
man this is the greatest
supreme court term this is such a this
is such a white pill
to talk like a kid on the internet you
know this is it's so easy to feel that
it's all lost and it's hopeless
especially after two years of
of covid and the lockdowns and the
fouchies of the world and the
international institutions and the
bureaucracies just taking away all of
our political rights and taking away not
just our rights and our liberties but
our traditional way of life and it just
seems like everything is slipping away
and we don't we're not even allowed to
wave the american flag anymore we're
going to replace all the american flags
with rainbows and we're going to protest
the american flag where we see it we're
going to knock down our statues we're
going to lose our guns and we're going
to lose our free speech and we're going
to just we're just we're going to lose
our representative democracy and we're
just going to lose everything
and then
and then it's even for me i'm a pretty
chipper guy i i was
i was losing hope politically
and
and now i'm not
now i'm not
so they're they're just giving me the
numbers here gorsuch wrote the opinion
it was a 6-3 decision
here's what here's what gorgeous
gorsuch's majority opinion says
coach kennedy's private religious
exercise did not come close to crossing
any line one might imagine separating
protected private expression
from impermissible government coercion
of course and of course we all knew it
we all if you knew anything about this
case if you had even heard the top line
description you would know of of course
it's not illegal illegal to have a
private prayer and thank god after a
football game but we just it it seemed
like the country was so far gone we were
so past that the the only book you can't
teach in schools is the bible all right
you can teach gay porn in elementary
schools you can trans the kids but you
can't read a passage of the bible out to
your class we just thought we were so
far gone especially on these issues of
religious liberty and then you just get
that hope which my friends
it's not just a nice happy feeling but
it's a fact it's a theological virtue
and it's a fact and this is a very
very good month i'm michael knowles this
is the michael knowles show see you
tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
bori supervising producer mathis glover
production manager pavel vadofsky editor
and associate producer danny d'amico
associate producer justine turley audio
mixer mike coromina and hair and makeup
by cherokee heart michael knowles show
is a daily wire production copyright
daily wire 20 22. today on the ben
shapiro show rage and tears abound as
roe is overturned democrats try to jazz
up their 2022 base but have no actual
plan and we examine which party is truly
extreme on abortion that's today on the
bench bureau shall give it a listen